اتجه الى العاصمه القطريه الدوحه ينضم
الينا من هناك منفد العربيه نايف الثقيل
اهلنا بك نايف نايف ما الجديد لديك حتى
الساعه
طبعا الجديد عبد الله كما تشاهد الان نحن
في احد التجمعات ودائما يكون كره القدم
تخلق السعاده لدى الجميع ولدي البسطاء هنا
يعني الجاليه التجمع للجاريه الهنديه وهما
بداوا بالاحتفال بفوز المنتخب البرازيلي
قبل نهايه المباراه عبد الله سعاده كبيره
تنتشر هنا وايضا لديهم ضابطه عبد الله
تحتفل بالاهداف وتحتفل باحداث المباراه
والتي يعني تذهب لصالح المنتخب البرازيلي
عبد الله هل هذا هل هذا التجمع وتجمع همم
يعني من تجمعات الفيفا الرسميه وانا اتجمع
همم
صنعته الجاريه الهنديه بنفسه نفسها ومن
هو هو من التجمعات اللي صنعتها الجاريه يا
عبد الله يعني وليس تجمع لفيفا بشكل رسمي
ولكن هو من التجمعات التي صنعتها الجاليه
الهنديه عبد الله وكما تشاهد عدد مهول
وعدد كبير وعبد الله من الجاني التي تشجع
المنتخب البرازيلي وتحتفل باهدافه
نايف ايضا اليوم تنتهي الجوله الاولى من
المونديال الجوله ما هي ابرز مشاهدات
باختصار وعلى عوجانا
عبد الله مشاهدات يعني ممكن عديده ممكن
تقصدها في الجوله الاولى هي همم فوز
المنتخب السعودي فوز المنتخب
الياباني
تعادلات المنتخبات العربيه والتي تعتبر
ايجابيه ما عدا همم قطر ايضا عبد الله
المشاهد التي تشاهدها الان والاحتفالات
الجميله من همم من كافه الجنسيات في مختلف
يعني عبد الله كمان تشاد كانهم يعني من
مواليد في هذه الاحتفالات
المنتخب البرازيلي نعم نايف هل هناك جديد
عن المنتخب السعودي واستعداداته لمباراه
القادمه
ابد عبد الله
الاستعدادات تجري على قدم وساق عبد الله
ونحن الان مبطلين الان للتوقف نعم لتوقف
البث عبد الله جيد نايف الثقيل المفضل
العربيه الى الدوحه حيث كاس العالم كنت
معنا شكرا جزيلا لك